普通にするとこれです
させの下すぎるランケ目をつけるとまぁかろうじてキモイですこれじゃあはじめしゃ
ちょーでしちょっと前髪切りすぎてテンションが低いです変ずつ
何故か今日は偏頭痛がひどいのでちょっと今日は旬って感じです
昔ですねぼくサーキュレーターをたくさん買ってそれでこう紙ヒコーキを a に
飛ばそうということを考えているんですけどもまぁ余裕のよっちゃんの無理でした
んですけどアナと僕ちょっといろいろ調べたり何か皆さんの情報をいただいていろいろ
調べたんですけどもたらネットでパンキュレーターを2つ使えば3今季が a に浮い
てるみたいな a に吹いてるみたいななんかそういう情報を聞いたので教授とそれは
実際にやってみると思います実家た将生とかねちょっとねみんなにあげちゃったんで
公約数減ったんですけど2つあればできるって聞いた本当にできたら本当に売れ
シーンですけどちょっと怖いんだけどやり方としてはサーキュレーター2つを
向かい合わせまして迎え合わせて多分同じ連中さにするのか
同じくらいの強誰にして微ちょうど通過に紙飛行機を置くとなんかこう年ずっと浮いて
たみたいなを見てわかると思うんですけど
スパイラル状になってるわけでスパイラル螺旋状になってるって程の回転力うまいこと
何か利用さ
御講義がずっとここでこうキープされるのかなって思いますこれがうまくいけば金飛行
共栄に浮かせるということが可能なので徐々にやってみるとパパの話があるんですけど
最近ポケモンゴーにはまってて頑張ってレベル重機が出来ましたありがとうですビール
[音楽]
紙一あの紙飛行機を作りましょう
前髪なんてキモエロやこれさでもさんわかんないんだよねそのネットの情報だったんで
新矯正にかけてますひょっとしたら誰かがたまたま合成で行っちゃっただけみたいな
そういう可能性はあるってこれが本当に正しいかどうかちょっとやってみるとわかん
ない前鑑定しました紙飛行機でございますまずは中ぐらいで行っ気がします熊倉山の
中心を捉える完璧な合戦の中心おこう
それで本当にで神の子ないきます
なんか絶対無理な気がしてきたこんなの無理いつだって絶対
[音楽]
これちょっとまた本当に見えちゃう
ネットでいつもこれでなっていたのにそれじゃあやります
もうちょっとは絶対無理でしょまあもしっかり合わせることから始めもぜひに授与する
ban
ふーん
パパ詰まって今何か今何か感じたよ@感じる
そうでもね何かおいしい役をするんだけどなん
もう怒った結局さ取り付けのはこれなんですよねこれも全然すごいんですけど
達成なれないのかこれはないほど使ってる気がするんですよね分かんないんですけどで
十全にこれ紙ヒコーキをずっと周ってるわけなんで
これなんかどうにかしたら着るのかなっていうもこれ津波に風の沙汰強めると動い
ちゃうんですよ
これ弱いかで専用のなんか必殺技みたいな感じがします
どうありますこれと言ってすると強すぎて撃っちゃうんですよ
なのでこの2位で浮いた状態にこの上からこれをこう壁ててこっちはザクにします
そして前と同様に均等を取れば少しずつ浮くのかなとか
無理かも山根ほど挑戦ですやってみましょうはいないなぁこれな紙飛行機の形に無理
じゃないダメだからメディアに言うでしょ
うーんまあ聞けば入っても続いて浮いてるいでる浮いてる関係抜いてる完全に見てる
完全にヤバイ
すごいすごい
チームだ者
me
あっはぁ
ございますて番が吹いて抜いてるで勝ってはいえばを得てるってはよ
ちょっと寄ってっては売っては増えているハッハー